Sanchez
save furniture Thanks to 1 negotiation in extremis
that makes yuns
and above all,
thanks to the support of the Canarian coalition,
that if it becomes the famous
yavín explained at the time by its President,
Fernando Clavijo.
The tense plenary session of the Congress of Deputies
held this Wednesday in the Senate,
while under construction,
the engineer
has seen once again as the Canarian coalition vote.
has been decisive.
Cristina's yes vote has been decisive in taking out
forward 2 of the 3 decrees voted on
and in the area of measures against the economic crisis
has special relevance
because it allows,
among other provisions,
the continuity of the buses and the streetcar in the
archipelago.
Vice President Díaz's decree fell at 1
move that Cola will bring from his former bandmates.
yunts' decision not to vote
recorded 1 result
of 172 yeses and 171 noes,
with what the vote of valid on the side of the majority
that made the investiture possible was key to